So, this was a very hard one lesson, so
I hope you appreciate it. Okay, here's
the point. So, basically what happened
is
Claude wrote an incorrect memory, okay?
And what happened is this incorrect
memory was relayed to the location of
The details don't actually matter.
Uh the point is that this incorrect
memory causes Claude to mislocalize
itself or poke the Pokémon to
mislocalize itself
and it falls through this trapdoor,
okay? That's the key point. So, writes
this incorrect memory, this incorrect
memory caused it to mislocalize in the
game, and it falls down this trap. And
this is very consistent, so I saw this
in five replicates, five out of five
replicates with raw memory store fell
down this trap. With dreaming this error
is corrected, and it's able to properly
localize itself and not fall fall down
this trap.